we've talked a lot about this with conor
mcgregor and floyd mayweather conor
mcgregor's talked a lot about it there
were rumors about it over the summer
Ariel Helwani covers the sport better
than anybody else mmafighting.com is his
a website and Ariel joins us now what do
you make of this Ariel and in the
embryonic stages of discussions or at
least trash talking here well first off
again dan thank you so much for having
me on the show what do I make of it to
be honest I think it's absolutely
ludicrous i think it's a it's a BS
storyline perpetuated by these you know
these morning debate shows because they
know nothing about mixed martial arts
and this is the only thing that they can
grab on to to meet look after the the
Cleveland Cavaliers won in June where
those same shows going on television
saying okay that was great they made
history but how would they do against
the Denver Broncos because that's the
same kind of discussion it's ludicrous
it's embarrassing and any journalists
who actually seriously debated this on
Monday two days after Connor made
history at MSG should be ashamed of
themselves but can you do something and
by the way thank you for telling me how
you really feel but is there a way to
modify this where you could actually do
something with with these two because
there's a lot of money at stake or at
least it feels like that so that's where
I always follow the money even as crazy
as it sounds look if they actually
figured out a way to get it done I have
no doubt that it would be the highest
selling pay-per-view that either boxing
or MMA could put on right now and that
includes mayweather pacquiao to
obviously would make a lot of money I
understand that there's this sort of
freak show factor to it I understand
that you know it's it's kind of like the
classic barbershop fight you know people
sit around and say okay what you know
Connor with his wrestling he could take
mayweather down Mayweather with his hand
speed he cannot Conrad I get it they're
both great trash talkers but it's just
fantasy it there are so many hurdles
that need to be jumped over for this
fight to actually happen it's just it's
a little disappointing as an MMA
journalist only because then i get it
i'm not trying to be like the guy who
saw his band grow up and now it's
mainstream and i'm longing for the
underground days but connor just made
history on saturday can we enjoy
way that and celebrate that before
talking about this fictitious fight that
probably will never happen that's my
take on the whole thing you know what
I'm saying but area like conor mcgregor
talked about it though whether he was
asked about it he said that you know
Floyd doesn't want any part of this you
know he people to sleep and I put him to
sleep by you know how I fight he puts
him by you know how he boxes so McGregor
has fed into this though in all fairness
well because he's the ultimate promoter
I mean I I bet if you asked him how he
would do against Bruce Lee in in 2017
he'd give you a nice answer for that one
as well I mean why wouldn't he feed into
this he stands to make more money
against Mayweather than ever in his
career look I actually feel like Connor
would do it I feel like the UFC would do
it I don't think Mayweather would do it
at this point why would he do it I mean
Mayweather doesn't want to step in there
against triple G why would he step in
there against Connor in a
no-holds-barred fight there's too much
for him to lose at this point is just
boxing though let's say they did
sanction it as a boxing match what do
you think well first of all I mean look
in in a perfect you know world where
where things are done the right way
conor mcgregor shouldn't be sanctioned
in a box against floyd mayweather
because Floyd Mayweather has 49
professional fights enders built-in
Connor has zero professional fights now
I'm not dumb I know that any Commission
in this universe would sanction this
fight including Nevada which is supposed
to be you know the fight capital the
world I think Connor would do it but he
would do it for 100 million and would
would Floyd split 100 million with with
Connor and give the UFC a piece of the
pie because the UFC is not going to just
sit back and let this happen they own
Connors rights right now Floyd doesn't
have that hurdle because he's his own
promoter Connor has a promoter who's the
UFC who expects and is used to making a
boatload of money more so than the
fighters so they're just not going to
let those guys take all the money and
that's a big problem as well and also
people look at conor mcgregor and go boy
you know he's a good fighter good boxer
for an MMA guy i said here you know what
he is for an MMA fighter but not as
Floyd Mayweather is tactically one of
the greatest defensive fighters of all
time and where all of a sudden going to
put conor mcgregor in that category that
he can you know even with the age
difference i went there's a big
difference in what Floyd does
and what Connor does when it comes to
boxing you're one hundred percent right
that's why I made the comparison to the
calves and the Broncos as opposed to the
calves in the 90s bulls because you
could say well yeah you know in in
basketball LeBron James runs and he
passes the ball just like Peyton Manning
did in the Super Bowl that's where the
two sports shared this common bond but
otherwise there are two completely
different sports the way Connor boxes is
completely different than the way Floyd
Mayweather boxes because Connor has to
worry about so much more he has to worry
about kicks and knees and take down I
mean it's a completely different mindset
so Connor has been learning to box as an
MMA fighter as opposed to Floyd who has
been learning to box offensively and
defensively only having to worry about
the punches coming to his face and to
his body it's so different and that's
why it's a very easy answer I don't
understand why people keep debating this
if it's a boxing match Floyd wins if
it's an MMA fight Connor wins I just
told you the the end of the movie why do
you people care about it so much I don't
get it I'm much rather talk about you
know Connor against khabib nurmagomedov
all the great fighters in his own sport
but I know that doesn't you know that
doesn't get the executives at these
respective TV stations excited what did
New York do for UFC oh man it was huge
it really felt like you know we kind of
made it our little sport that could made
it I think everyone you know kind of
played a part in that in fact in the
shocker of all shockers at the very end
of the night at the end of the press
conference your good friend Dana White
even thanked the media for their part in
doing that you know how big of a deal
that is for him so it was it was a nice
moment everyone was very happy and it
was just kind of surreal after all these
years dreaming about what would the
first show at MSG look like who would
headline it what would it look like you
know who would win who would be the
stars going into it and then we're
finally there and not only do we get
there but history is actually made conor
mcgregor becomes the first man to hold
two titles at the same time you can't
script it better than that and and now
it just feels like he has reached this
whole other stratosphere I mean Marc
Gasol I don't know if you saw this yeah
it hits the game-winning shot and he's
copying conor mcgregor this is crazy so
it feels like we reached another level
it's one thing to do all that in vegas
or in dublin or you know in California
it's another thing to do that at msg on
Broadway in front of Madonna huge act
Odell Beckham and that's what Connor did
so it feels like we're in a different
sort of stratosphere now after Saturday
night I will try not to bother with
trivial things again Ariel no no I love
it I love it but I just feel like I have
to sort of you know on behalf of my
sport that I love so dearly I have to
kind of bring everyone down because all
week I've been seeing these talking
heads who know nothing about MMA who
don't really understand how to put what
Connor did in context just grab on to
this low hanging fruit talk about what
he did talk about why why he's so great
why he's just such an amazing MMA
fighter don't don't go for this stuff
you guys are better than that I know
you're better than that thanks for the
passion my pleasure thank you as always
Ariel Helwani mmafighting.com the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience